We're going to make this change to the app we've been working on,
and we've got to do two things.
We need to make a thanks handler.
We need to add the thanks URL,
and we need to redirect to the thanks URL.
Okay, let's go ahead and do these.
Here we are--we have the functions you're familiar with, our normal form handler.
Let's go down to the bottom of our file and add a new handler.
I've added the definition for the thanks handler.
This has the same structure as our other handler.
It has a name, and then it inherits from webapp 2 request handler.
We're going to add a get function to it for get requests.
We're going to take this behavior from here and move it down here.
Okay, now we have our handler.
Let's do the redirect here.
So instead of printing thanks we're going to redirect.
This is how you do redirects in google apps.
You call the function redirect on self in a handler,
and it will redirect you to the URL that you provide.
We don't have to say HTTP here because we're redirecting to the same domain.
So we can just specify the path.
We need to do one final thing.
We need to add the thanks URL.
We need to map it this handler; so let's go ahead and do that.
Okay, I added another URL down here in our mapping area.
It maps /thanks to the thanks handler.
Let's go ahead and test this in the browser.
We reload our page, we enter in a valid date, and we click submit.
Now, remember submit is going to give us a redirect
instead of just sending us data in the post.
Here we go.
We are now at /thanks, and our web application is saying thanks.
Now we can reload this page as much as we want,
and we don't get any silly resubmit this form thing.
I can share this link with my friends and say look how smart I am.
I know my birthday.
They will be suitably impressed.
The server won't have to validate our form over and over again.
Okay, that's it for basic forms.
Thanks very much.